people say to me howard how did ronnie
become a big star on your show and i'll
tell you how
the guy's an open book honesty this guy
once walked into my studio and started
talking about how
after he shits he puts his ass in the
sink and he washes out his [ __ ] and i
said to myself
a star is born all of a sudden something
happened to ronnie
where he's clamming up and i don't
understand why it's not like ronnie
i'm just being a dick now that's all
nobody's saying that nobody's saying
that i'm i'm telling you
i'm being a dick gary i don't want to
know who you're voting for i don't give
a [ __ ] i don't want to know the only
question i want to
know is why don't you want to talk about
it just because you guys are piling on
my [ __ ] ass
constantly i'll never say who i'm voting
for all we get is
angry ronnie now i'm not angry i'm fine
i'm not i'm not angry it doesn't sound
very calm
it kind of helped me make a decision
about a couple of things and it was
great
that sounds very cryptic that you uh
made a couple of decisions
what happened there things happened
that's all people what happened
things happened why the things they said
and how they made me feel
made me make a decision about certain
things that i had to do
now we got cryptic ronnie
not cryptic i actually i thank those
people who
basically told me to go [ __ ] yourself
you're not my friend anymore because you
never wore my friend
we just really have nothing in common as
people i'm sorry i'm retiring from this
whole deal at the end of the year
i don't want to work at a [ __ ] place
where i'm not liked that maybe make the
decision to go ahead and do something
that
i was afraid to do what do you think
ronnie's big decision was
it gave me that little push now i'll
tell you you really want to know i'll
tell you yes
okay back in march we were supposed to
go
out to vegas uh and then this all
happened the covert thing
we had to cancel it but this past
vacation
we got on a plane and we went to vegas
for nine days we found the house that we
want and we're just waiting now to find
uh we have two bids on a lot and we're
waiting to see which one we're gonna get
and then construction can start i feel
chris wilding this is your fault
no it's nobody's fault i'm not i'm not
blaming you it's just
i don't know gave me the push to do it
are you guys happy with yourselves you
pushed
me chris you pushed ronnie out the door
i did not say they pushed me i think
they gave me a little push a little bit
a little bit of pokemon you said it was
a push
i pushed you you weren't gonna go to
vegas all right i'll tell you what chris
i'll release your guilt i don't have any
guilt
i don't care what he says i don't care
what he feels
i'm not a martyr you were creating this
scenario in your head that never
happened
what's the narrative we all got you into
a corner with shanks
and we surrounded you and we said you
better do this or we're going to get you
nobody said never happened i didn't say
did i say that don't put words in my
mouth but that's how you were acting
yeah and you're acting like a dictator
okay how am i that you you get on the
air and this is what you do to people
because they come on
here and i say what you do this is what
you do
if you vote you can't even vote get it
wrong you don't even have a saying i
do have a voice of america
[Music]
[ __ ] citizenship [ __ ] united
[ __ ]
[ __ ] all right
[Music]
well guys i have to stop this you got
your [ __ ] air time be
happy man yeah all right thank you chris
yeah
well you know it gets ugly why'd he
[ __ ] take his face off the [ __ ]
camera all of a sudden huh
i stuck an [ __ ] it's like when sasha
baron cohn
went into the rudy giuliani room you
know and he stopped it
all i could say is i can't wait to go to
my empty lot in vegas and stare
for those of us here in new york will be
sad to see ronnie go
but i understand what you're up to and i
and i support it
thank you
you